gone are the days where a system  administrator had to interact with the  UI to manually configure hundreds of  servers networks and firewall rules  with the rapid scaling of it  infrastructure devops teams are  struggling to efficiently manage the  growing business needs they need  technology that can scale rapidly  eliminate operational bottlenecks close  communication loops and reduce the  frequency human errors so they use IAC  or infrastructure as code IAC which is a  foundational concept of terraform is  managing and provisioning infrastructure  through a configuration language instead  of UI  with IAC you can commit version trace  and collaborate just like any other  source code  are you ready to learn more click on the  three dots and then click on the link in  the description box to enroll in the  getting started with terraform for  Google Cloud course see you there